even crazier is if you go into patreon
you can see how long people have been
giving money in the exact amount over
time so you can go on someone like like
Kong like we see Kong on there that
fool's racked up like thousands of
dollars of patreon we're like really
it's like he can actually say without me
you ain't keeping the JK lights on yeah
yeah you're the only one man
[Music]
you guys been seeing uh what's going on
with doji cat lately no what's happening
bro well not not physically not like
that I remember the red suit she had on
that was pretty crazy what was the red
suit got a whole like red diamond type
of suit she wore was it like the Sam Sam
Smith red she gets in trouble a lot so
let's show us show us yeah people get
mad at her yeah this thing whoa
pineapple juice
yeah it's pretty crazy interesting
that's wild interesting you like it not
really no what is the theme
what's the theme Chinese New Year
she's trying to be a red packet yeah
she's trying to be her a red envelope
She's Somebody's gift so right now she's
she's been doing something lately that I
actually think is is pretty cool drugs
no not drugs what's she doing but uh
equally is interesting so um she's
probably one of the first major
celebrities that I've seen do this where
like she's basically losing following on
purpose that's cool wait she's doing
that for sure she's the one responding
to people yeah so like uh she says so
she's got a fandom they call themselves
kittens the same way that like the BTS
people call themselves Army right and
then she says if you call yourself a
kitten or [__] kittens that means you
need to get off your phone and get a job
and help your parents with the house she
doesn't enjoy the fandom at this level
and she's uh she's like you guys make
the worst fans get the [__] out of here
get a job
so far she's lost more than half a mil
Instagram followers and she says she's
never felt like more free like because
somebody was even saying to her like how
dare you like uh I guess they were
saying I love you and she was like I
don't love you guys I don't even know
you and then they were like on a fire
like the fans were starting to say for
someone to say that yeah and then the
fans were even saying uh like how dare
you speak like that to us you would be
nothing without us see that's hilarious
too entitlement from like fans like that
and it's it's finally like a celebrity
that's actually in the mainstream that's
willing to say I don't give a [__] I
don't know you it's pretty crazy that is
pretty wild yeah she's saying she says
here seeing all these people unfollow
makes me feel like I've defeated a large
beast that's been holding me down for so
long and it feels like I can reconnect
with the people who really matter and
love me for who I am and not for who I
was
whoa yeah pretty cool it's like fighting
against the industry that's the fact
because I'm sure there's like a weird
level of stardom that some people get
where their fans almost want to like
I don't say control you but they have
almost too much investment well they
also don't like when you change and
she's been she changes a lot you know is
that what like doji cat doesn't look the
same way that she did earlier but like
so what you know oh people were getting
mad at her for like how she changed her
appearance they get they'll get mad at
you because you're not who they followed
like originally yeah hardcore fans be
about that too and because they also
like their whole world will revolve
around that fandom so they might like
you know their friends know them as a
fan of this person and then so I
subscribe to this person but if this
person changes into something that may
be like oh wait a minute I normally
wouldn't be a fan they feel like they've
been threatened in some way too by the
things that they've already you know
shared in terms of the interest so
that's why so many like and this we we
talked about this before this happens in
like the K-pop industry a lot too right
that's why they have to be a certain way
they can't tell people about their
relationships because the second they're
like oh I actually have a girlfriend
it's like all those little girly fans
will suddenly be like wait a minute
right you betrayed us you're supposed to
be yeah you're supposed to be my husband
and it's it's just like uh Jackson
Wang's fans tripping over Anthony when
he was interviewing them like dude it's
just friends talking they think they're
protecting Jackson they're protecting it
but like from the snake and then uh Jojo
cat says uh my theory is that if someone
has never met me in real life then
subconsciously I'm not real to them so
when people become engaged with someone
they don't even know they kind of take
ownership over that person they think
that person belongs to them they don't
treat them like a human anymore they
don't see him I think that's the main
thing he's like treat them like another
human at least yeah for sure that's true
yeah I mean we felt that on a smaller
scale too where we had
weird fans like that would say they're
hardcore fans and then like some drama
happens and stuff and then like they
immediately turn pick sides cause more
issues rumors right and it's like when a
lot of those weird ones left
it became a way better Channel like
comments but got better like everything
got so much better I agree because I
like the people that that talk to us
that are fans they talk to us like
people they'll just send they'll send a
stupid video and be like hey what you
think about this [__] and I'll be like
that's tight and I'll talk to them like
we're just people like nothing that
crazy but in this level it's like you
think at that height you have to be more
careful about it but she's actually
being less careful and being like [__]
it because she says when a person
changes drastically there's a shock
response that is almost uncontrollable
I've accepted that that's what happens I
have all the freedom in the world and
that's probably her thing it's like if
she wants to be who she is and she
changes and everybody gets shocked and
starts giving her [__] she doesn't have
to take that but it's also funny that
she is right about she shouldn't be your
world yeah for real she's like yeah I'm
just entertainment right that's what I
actually love about her because it's
like she's not also so full of herself
where some entertainers feel like
god-like yeah yeah and I can see why
because every they're surrounded by yes
people they have people worshiping them
whatever in her case she's like go get a
[__] job you loser I'm not the most
important thing don't worry about me
dude it's like like my music like my
[__] okay but then go on with your lives
and do stuff yeah imagine being a fan of
her and she says all that stuff and you
take it so personal or you unfollower
and be like I hate her now like that's
also a weird flip that's weird yeah
right like you shouldn't care about
someone else that much you should be
worrying about you affected by somebody
that you've never met definitely her fan
pages with the highest amount of
followings have deleted themselves oh
damn pretty [__] cool I wonder how
many of them are actually didn't that
work didn't that affect like the the
income a lot too as far as like she
might be too big at this point yeah
she's she I'm sure she yeah maybe the
despair the disparity is negligible at
that amount yeah and also too it's like
sometimes you gotta shed some fans maybe
that's gonna give her a new life like it
and it is it is a new type of news it's
a new type of headline for like the dog
is that big and on top of that too it's
like you don't hear when you're in that
place of power you never hear anyone
saying hey you know it's mad funny I
love my fans I love you guys and you
have you have all the reasons to not do
that just to let you guys know stop
watching JK news go get a [__] job
and watch us at your work yeah yeah yeah
while you make money get a job so you
can get on patreon the funniest thing
would be if this starts a trend and all
these artists start to say [__] my fans
I hate you go get a job do you all think
it's gonna like work for them positively
too how many of those fans you think
actually said you know what I am a
[__] loser I need to get a job
I don't know man I really don't
I don't know how that works that's a lot
of influence I think these artists are
getting just tired because like a fans
throwing things on stage just being oh
dude the disrespect disrespect now for
performers it's like I'm I'm here
entertaining you this is essentially a
show
um there's a boundary that's been
crossed I think more so now than ever
maybe because social media did close in
the Gap because before social media like
they were actual like Gods like
Superstars were Superstars they were
unreachable you can't talk to them like
without getting through some middle
person or whatever and it was like a
huge like mystery behind it all right
and they weren't always under the
Limelight yeah with every [__] thing
they did you know what I mean social
media is just now if you're if you're
like a celebrity celebrity on your
social media you're just everywhere your
whole your [__] moms in social media
like one little thing and it's just like
a trickle effect you could tweet
something and seven years later dude
trouble for it you know like you didn't
say sorry to this person oh my God
that's true yeah he gets [__] dug up
from like way back yeah this is why you
gotta do the live streams where yeah you
do the NPC stuff that's what that that's
the new wave dude I love those ice cream
so good this isn't a similar thing but
um but it makes me think about it I
remember when like Lady Gaga right
obviously when she came up into her like
pop stardom and stuff like the things
that she was doing the way she was doing
it was so unique so much Flash and
Pizzazz and Flair things that she was
wearing the way that she was dressing
and acting like it was very over the top
right and it built a fandom but at the
same time the second she got to a place
of success she like took a break and
decided to go back to like Broadway and
sing in like smaller shows and jazzy
piano and like doing things that she
really really was about because she like
found success from it and I feel like
that's kind of like sometimes the most
ideal approach like in the way that the
fan was kind of correct and being like
don't you cat you wouldn't be here if it
wasn't for us like they're kind of right
you know what I mean but at the same
time when you as a fan give somebody
that power they have the right to use
that power you know what I'm saying like
you already gave it to them so if they
have like a a specific life that they
actually want to lead after having been
given such fandom from people it's like
all the power to them regardless if you
end up staying a fan of them or not you
know what I mean like you gave them the
money like let them make the choices you
gave them the attention let them make
their deal what happened to allowing not
allowing but people are allowed to
change regardless just as human beings
but celebrities aren't because we're
just
you know we place them on this pedestal
of like this is the identity that I uh
became a fan of and therefore you're not
allowed to change outside that Spectrum
but as a human you're like I I want to
change through different phases of my
life sure and you should be allowed to
right it's natural I don't even know if
people are allowed to change now because
they'll pull up a tweet 20 years ago
that you said and then they'll put that
against you and be like good you said
you'd never change
it's so simple you said that once you
probably still mean it that's why
absolutely you worked with her before
right didn't you say you had a shoot
with Doja cat oh no no no no no do a
Lipa do a Libra do a Libra
I don't think dual people would say that
to her fans probably not she probably
wouldn't have to yeah she wouldn't but
that's like the difference is that when
you say like if let's say you were
talking to your fans and you said like I
would I wouldn't be here without you
I don't think that's talking to every
kind of fan I think some fans you would
still be here yeah yeah especially like
the toxic ones like you could do without
them I think and I don't think it would
hurt you that much because I think
that's a small but very loud percentage
yeah they're talking about all the fans
from all over the years yeah who came
and went but also gave time to share
that experience yeah there's still a lot
not one [__] that's obsessed and die
hard and stalkerish yeah yeah there's
still a lot of people
support your products you think one
[__] and stalker is gonna make their
career like shut up bro just like JK
like how many people sometimes will
comment for the first time in like 13
years and they'll be like hey I've never
said anything but thanks for still being
around you know what's cool on the
um account Channel like login end we can
see next to their name how many years
they've been subscribed and some of them
are like 12 years 13 14 like
and so I know if they're lying because
they'll be like I've been watching for
over a decade and I'm scrolling over I'm
like that's been eight years liar
to your shorts even crazier is if you go
into patreon you can see how long people
have been giving money in the exact
amount over time so you can go on
someone like like Kong like we see Kang
on there that fool's racked up like
thousands of dollars of patreon he can
actually say without me you ain't
keeping the JK lights on yeah yeah
you're the only one man thank you so
much you're right we love you
ha
[Music]
foreign